one of the things that i did by the way
um which i implemented in my own
business was
when i would hire people i would
actually go through quite a bit
to identify that they were a good
candidate
and one of the tests that i would
implement i usually do this about a week
after i hired them actually
um this isn't something that you can do
obviously with a girl you're dating or
with friends so for those of you that
are entrepreneurs or aspiring
entrepreneurs
this will be useful in your business um
but i learned this technique
and i adapted it very very quickly
because i found it to be very effective
i'd hire them very slowly do all the
training and about a week after i hired
them about a week after they
had time uh at the task at hand we're
doing the job we're in the office
interacted with people who were using
the systems
had an opportunity to work with
management and see how
they gelled i'd call them in my office
and i'd sit them down and you know
without any kind of warrant i'd be like
hey you know how things going
you know you're enjoying stuff yep yep
they'd always just nod their head very
grateful to be there blah blah blah
and i'd say how about if i give you a
thousand dollars to quit the job right
now
right um and i would start bidding it i
think i would bid it up
normally to about two thousand dollars
um and
for the most part if i did a good job
hiring slowly and vetting them for the
role
most people would say it doesn't matter
what you offer me today you could offer
me five thousand dollars i wouldn't quit
okay i wouldn't take the money and go
this was basically a firing bonus
and what i wanted to do was i wanted to
see if they really wanted to be there
because somebody that really wanted to
be there would again turn around and say
it doesn't matter if you pay me
three five ten thousand dollars i don't
care i love this i want to stay here i
like this company
i like what's you know what's going on
here i did have one
person i think the entire time who i
suspected wasn't going to stay for very
long he was a younger kid
and he needed to be outdoors and work
with his hands was what i figured out at
the end of it he was one of the early on
ones that i made a mistake on
but um yeah he took um i don't know
maybe 1200 bucks and i sent him home so
the good part of that from my
perspective and somebody out there might
be going well that's stupid why would
you pay somebody 1200
to or fire them like why would you just
fire them because i want to see
what their intention is with me and my
business
and how serious they are about being
there because if they're not serious
about being there and they're just there
to collect a paycheck and they're going
to bounce anyway in a few months time
and waste my time and waste the time of
my customers who they
tend to form a good relationship with i
want them out now i don't want them
to linger around for a few months maybe
even potentially have to pay them
considerably more to get them out of the
business because you've got to pay a
severance package and
there's all sorts of other costs that
come out of that so
i used to call this offering people a
bonus to quit
and it worked very well so you guys
consider that if you know you're running
your own business uh i found it very
very effective uh
separating the wheat from the chaff and
making sure i got rid of people that did
not want to be there
were not a good fit and it saved me a
lot of money in the long run
you